In the last video, we saw that
if Ben's Shoe Company's stock
prices are trading
at $21.50 per share,
and if Ben's Shoe Company
has 10,000 shares--
and we saw that over here on the
left, if it had 10,000 shares.
Actually both of the shoe
companies have 10,000 shares.
Then the market is
essentially valuing the equity
of Ben's Shoe
Company at $215,000,
even though the book value
of the equity was $135,000.
What I want to do
in this video is
think about what does
that mean, or how
should we perceive
the market's value
of the assets of
Ben's Shoe Company.
Then we can also think
about Jason's Shoe Company.
So remember, assets are
equal to liabilities
plus the shareholders' equity.
So if all of a sudden the market
value of the equity, the market
capitalization for
Ben's Shoe Company
is $215,000, that's the
equity part right over here,
this is the equity.
And the only liability
that Ben's Shoe Company had
was this $5,000 in
accounts payable.
So let me show you
that right over here,
he had this $5,000
in accounts payable,
also depicted over there.
So the only liability
is this $5,000.
So the liabilities
plus the equity,
in the case of Ben's company,
is $215,000 plus $5,000.
So this piece right
over here is $220,000.
Now, you might remember
from previous videos
that the book value of the
assets in Ben's company
are only $140,000.
$20,000 of cash, $100,000
of inventory, $20,000-- this
isn't equity, this
is equipment, I
should call it--
$20,000 of equipment.
So
The question is,
what makes up the gap
here, when we think about the
market value of the equity?
Because remember, this piece
right here only adds up
to $140,000.
But our total assets-- or
the market's perception
of the total assets
of the company--
are essentially what
it's willing to pay
for the equity
plus the liability.
So the market is saying that
Ben's assets, the assets
in that company,
are worth $220,000.
So what makes the difference?
And even better, let's
assume that Ben has actually
done a good job of
saying the market
value of his inventory, the
market value of his equipment.
Well, what the market's
saying in this situation--
and this is actually what
tends to happen in general,
the market value of
a company's equity
tends to be higher than
the book value-- is
that this company has
some type of intangibles.
Things that you really can't put
a finger on, or touch, or feel,
or hold.
But it makes this company's
assets-- or this company
has more than just
the sum of its parts.
There's more to this company
than just the equipment,
the inventory, and the cash.
It might be Ben's
management expertise.
It might be a certain way
they have of doing business.
It might be a certain
location they have.
It might be their assortment.
Who knows what it has,
but the market is saying
that the combination of this
plus all of the expertise
and how the business
is organized
means that it actually has more
assets than are on the books.
And the same thing is true
of Jason's company, when
they assign a $120,000
market cap there.
This is the $120,000 in
equity-- market value of equity.
He has another $105,000
in liabilities.
So the market's valuing
their equity plus liabilities
at $225,000.
Is that right?
120 plus 100 plus 5.
So 225,000.
So once again, they're valuing
all of the assets at $225,000,
because assets are
equal to liabilities--
these are the liabilities
right here-- plus equity.
So once again,
you're saying there's
something above and
beyond the $140,000 that
makes this company special.
And an interesting
thing to think about--
and we'll address it
in the next video--
is which one is a
better deal, considering
that these companies
are pretty similar?